I mean, if we wanna turn the death of the earth into capital,
we're doing a good job.
And then what do you do with that capital?
I mean, what meaning does money have
if it's an unlivable planet.
(upbeat music)
Greetings earth dwellers, welcome to the podcast.
My guest today,
back for his second appearance on the show
is an icon, a true legend.
One of the environmental movements leading voices,
Paul Hawken.
In addition to his profound work
as a planetary change agent,
Paul is also an entrepreneur.
He founded both Erewhon markets and Smith and Hawken
and author of eight books,
including the groundbreaking
New York times bestseller Drawdowm.
Now Paul is back with an astonishing, beautiful new book
called Regeneration,
ending the climate crisis in one generation,
as well as a corresponding nonprofit by the same name,
regeneration.org,
a collective work that together aims to guide and inspire
the burgeoning climate movement.
Paul is a friend, he's a mentor, he's a lighthouse
and a man who has indelibly shaped my perspective,
my philosophy and my actions
when it comes to ecological responsibility.
It's an honor to host him today.
This is a remarkable exchange
and my intention and hope
is that this message will do for you
what it has and continues to do for me.
So please click that subscribe button
and notification bell and enjoy my conversation
with the great Paul Hawken.
Well, let's talk about the environment.
Okay. Let's talk about the environment.
Should we do that?
Yeah.
It's good to see you first of all.
Really good to see you.
Yeah, thank you for coming.
I hear you so much you know,
like I feel like I'm in your presence.
I appreciate that.
No, I am.
Yeah, we had all these plans of getting together
and doing all kinds of stuff
and obviously the pandemic put that aside,
but I'm happy to be in your presence today.
Thank you so much, really.
The occasion of course, being this beautiful,
extraordinary new book,
that's about to come out,
regeneration ending the climate crisis in one generation,
you gave me this gorgeous folio version of the book.
Only a few exist in the world.
Yes,
Is that true.
That's true.
I'm feeling very grateful for that.
So thanks.
Yeah, It just is a special people.
It's exciting.
It's been a minute since you've had a book out.
Yeah, April 17 was the last book Drawdown
and this one is coming out
in about six countries almost at the same time,
actually 54 countries right now in September.
Right from the get go out of the gate that's unusual.
That's too confident.
Yeah. This time the publishers are.
last time, they were kind of waiting
and watching and looking.
Now Drawdown is in 17 languages.
Right.
Well, that book was a ground breaker
for myself and so many people.
And I feel like this book is the perfect
follow up to that in that
it strikes perhaps an even more optimistic tone
when it comes to solving this great existential crisis
that we find ourselves in.
But I think the overarching theme of it
is inclusion like inclusivity.
And it's very empowering in the sense that
it's like letting us into all these amazing things
that are occurring and how we can participate in them
in so many different ways.
Absolutely. I'm just like everybody else in a sense.
I live in a world.
I look at the world and try to figure it out.
I mean, I'm no different whether I'm a journalist or not,
doesn't make any difference.
Everyone does that to a certain extent.
And a journalist might do a bit more
because they try to share what they see
and what I have seen
and not just since Drawdown was created,
but before that,
but certainly since then
is a world is going into crisis around climate
and more rapidly than was expected.
And at the same time,
even though I would say a majority of the people
in the United States certainly and in Europe are empathetic,
sympathetic, understand the basic cause and effects.
They're not doing anything.
They're not engaged.
So how could it be,
that you see the writing on the wall,
you see this impending crisis,
you're getting a very visceral sense of what's happening,
on the ground and floods and cold and heat
and drought and et cetera.
And yet there's still this disengagement.
And so regeneration was really about looking at that,
not blaming people for being disengaged,
but trying to understand why we are not.
And I'll just clear myself generally,
but what would engage us?
And what's prohibiting it,
what's stopping us and what would open up humanity
to the idea of working together?
Yeah. I think from a psychological perspective,
there doesn't seem to be a meaningful
on-ramp for people in the sense that
I think you're correct.
There's an overwhelming awareness now
that didn't exist perhaps even a decade ago.
And I think most people are good faith actors
and wanna do the right thing
and recycle or do what they can,
but it doesn't feel like any of these things
amount to very much, right?
Like I can take personal responsibility
for a certain subset of decisions that I make every day,
but is this really moving the needle?
So there's a lack of agency or connectivity
to the solutions that would really get people
emotionally engaged
and feeling like they actually are making a difference.
Absolutely. I think that
there's so many things you covered right there.
So break it open a little bit.
It's got a connectivity,
which is that the root cause of global warming
is a massive disconnection between each other,
between people, between people in nature and nature itself,
which is caused by humans,
habitat fragmentation, pollution
desertification of the oceans and onwards.
And so regenerating and reversing the climate crisis
is really about reconnecting those broken strands.
And that's what the solutions really are,
as opposed to sort of standalone techniques or technologies,
that is going to fix it.
That word fix doesn't even belong in the conversation
because it's not an it,
and you can't fix it.
The atmosphere is the biosphere
that's the same thing and we are a part of it.
And nature never makes a mistake only we do.
So let's look at what we're doing.
And regeneration is very much about alignment
with the living world,
with the way it works and always has.
And so, as you said,
what we've done conversationally
and sort of declaratively
and almost imperatively
is individuate the problem,
which is this is what you can do or should do.
And it's true.
Those are good things,
recycling and use cold water in your wash machine,
and try not to drive an EV if you can afford it,
et cetera, et cetera.
But I think people understand that even if they do them,
they know it's not sufficient to the task at hand.
And so actually makes people more disempowered
in a funny way,
even though they're actually participating
in the kind of token way.
And then they look to governments,
they look to the conference of the parties,
the UN framework on climate change.
They look for these annual meetings,
just one in Glasgow, in November
for something to happen,
like hoping that politicians will get together
and solve the problem.
If politicians knew what to do,
we wouldn't be in the situation we are today.
And that's just not gonna happen.
Not to say we can say it.
So then you feel like there's this gulf
between these huge Meta or institutions,
corporations and governments,
and then you as an individual.
And that's, again,
what regeneration is trying to say, whoa, wait a minute.
that's not where the solution is gonna come from.
Right.
Regeneration is sort of bedfellows
with this idea of symbiosis.
Like how can we live more symbiotically on the planet
and understanding that,
and really embodying that
begins with really fully embracing and acknowledging
that we are all micro systems
that are part of a macro system.
And it's sort of belying the idea
that nature is over there
and we're over here
and we venture into nature and out of nature.
And yet, fundamentally that's just a false,
because the cells in our body
and everything that we're made up of
is of course part and parcel of this environment.
And in terms of the solution,
once you acknowledge that,
I think what you begin to understand
what the book kind of does a beautiful job conveying
is the idea that there's this,
the problem is systemic,
that we can't truly move into,
this more symbiotic regenerative relationship
with the planet until we have some corrective measures
with our systems at large, right?
There's this gigantic misalignment of incentives
across the board, be it by dent of governmental bodies
or the tectonic plates of capitalism,
all of these forces that the individual feels powerless
to have any control over or say over
that perpetuate the problem.
So, short of revolution,
like how are we creating better incentives
for the systems that are in play?
Or how do we create better systems
with incentives that could supplant the systems
that are leading us astray?
That is the question.
And I think that between the individual
and meta institutions and global institutions
is something else called agency.
And agency is sort of been overlooked.
There is no such thing as an individual.
That's sort of a delusion we wake up with in the morning.
And, but functionally, there's no such thing.
And every person has agency.
It's their family.
As their friends, it's their community,
it's their neighborhood, it's their churches
or synagogues or school.
It's where they teach, it's their city.
It's their company, colleagues.
It goes on and on and on.
And we have a network we're part of networks.
And that is where we have influence
and where we can make a difference.
And I think a lot of people have felt,
come to think that,
if we get renewables right,
or we do this, we do that.
that again, we'll fix it,
but like there's some Archimedean solution.
If we pull hard enough the problem is gonna go away.
Right.
And rather than understanding that
the solution is everywhere,
it's ubiquitous, it's local, regional.
It's where agency exists.
And that is everywhere on earth
with every culture,
every society and every country.
And so that's the good news,
which is that we can solve this, we really can.
but we can't solve it,
if we think someone's gonna solve it for us.
Or if we come to believe that individuals are to blame
and that the responsible and they'll solve it,
we kinda know that one's not true.
Right.
I'm not saying we all have,
we don't have personal responsibility.
Of course we do.
But that alone is going to be sufficient.
And so when we look at the institutions
with the perverse incentives that they have,
the economic institutions, the political institutions,
they are all extractive.
That is to say every institution that we've come to know
and trust or not trust, but buy from, or believe in,
or invest in or own shares in,
is extractive.
And there was this taking life.
And we sort of take that for granted
that don't make a mess,
we'll clean up your mess,
that kind of thing.
And that's sustainability in a way,
but extraction is taking life.
And when you take life,
that's degeneration,
that's what degeneration is when you take life.
And so regeneration is really not about blaming
and sort of demonizing
those institutions or those economic sectors
so much the same way.
that road, that degeneration road doesn't go much further.
That's everything's screaming at us,
all the science, our experiences, and so forth.
Like that road doesn't go much further.
Why are we going down that road?
And so regeneration is about a 180 pivot.
Like, can we just stop and go the other way?
Can we not regenerate the world and have a GDP
and an economy and jobs rather than degenerate it?
And the fact is we can,
and it's really a question of healing,
the future of stealing the future,
because what we're doing is stealing the future.
Now it used to be from our children.
Now it's from ourselves practically.
And so it really isn't like
I could say something that what's happening
with respect to climate is wrong
or not at all.
It's all great.
What everybody's doing is fantastic.
But unless we actually do address
those institutional incentives,
and actually assumptions that are so deep,
that people don't even understand them as assumptions,
then we won't have a chance at all,
because the...
one of the things to go back to the fix it thing,
like bill gates and others,
like John Kerry, for example, are saying,
if we don't do nuclear, we're screwed, okay.
And this idea that there is this one thing,
but you could have renewable energy
or nuclear energy for the whole world today.
And we'd still be going right over the cliff
because we're destroying all the living systems on earth.
We're destroying our oceans, our fisheries, our land,
our forest, our insects our pollinators.
And so that has nothing to do with renewable energy
or fossil fuel energy,
that has to do with us.
And so we have to see it, as you said earlier,
as the system is whole,
you can't silo it and separate it out and say,
we're gonna do that and do this and do that.
You can do that,
but unless you step back and look at it systemically,
you're not gonna get to the core cause or core cure.
But the idea being with this,
kind of typical optimistic flare
that you have being that,
we can create a non extractive relationship
with the planet without having to,
throw capitalism to the wind,
like within certain confines of the system
that we've erected,
we can course correct and still create proper incentives.
I mean the extraction would, I guess,
would be the economic benefit
that someone would get out of changing the relationship
with the planet to be symbiotic and regenerative.
Well, the capitalist system really takes life
and turns it into money.
Right.
It squeezes every last...
And being extractive by its very nature.
Right.
But you're saying that still within that
we can move in a better direction here.
What is that?
That's a really good question
because nobody invented the capitalist system.
It was named after the fact
in a sense economic systems arise.
And then we kind of tag them later.
I don't know what a regenerative economic system
will be called.
I don't think it'll be called capitalistic.
It doesn't mean that existing institutions and businesses
have to go out of business and we need to replace them.
I'm not saying that at all,
but the advent of the big core
and the different types of corporations
and so forth that have a very different priority
in terms of their purpose.
Yeah.
And part of that priority
is short-term gains over long-term.
Right.
You know, well-being for all, right?
Absolutely.
So that's a tough one to tackle.
Well, I mean,
if we wanna turn the death of the earth into capital,
we're doing a good job.
And then what are you gonna do with that capital?
I mean, what meaning does money have
if it's an unlivable planet?
And so I think,
but I do think you're seeing in corporations
a real big shift.
I'm not talking about the old commitment
to net zero by 2050, all that sort of stuff.
Commitments don't mean a thing.
Goals don't mean a thing.
They don't do anything.
They're not actions.
They're just commitments, just words.
But in my experience in the last couple of years
and even during COVID,
what you're seeing,
when you talk to CEOs of very large companies,
very large ones,
the largest in the world
is their eyes are different.
What I mean by that is
they're not being nice and saying,
yo, we have to renew our social license
and do more sustainability and blah, blah, blah.
Which is what they've been doing, kind of,
they get it, they have children,
they have brothers and sisters, have family.
That's a pretty big paradigm shift.
It's a really big one.
and they find themselves getting it
so to speak,
when they're at the helm
of these extraordinary corporations
that have hundreds of thousands of employees
and they're in 42 countries or whatever,
and going, huh.
And so that's what I'm seeing now,
as opposed to this suave, or shored,
just we'll just keep moving along
and we'll hire some more.
Dusting of green washing on top
to make sure that we take the press
off our back or whatever, right?
Yeah, no.
And so you're seeing companies like Nestle,
which talk about a bad boy reputation 20 years ago
for baby formula in Africa.
I mean just,
but they went through a couple more CEOs since then,
who really, really cleaned up their act.
They've sold off all their plastic water bottle companies.
Probably the biggest
single use plastic manufacturer in the world.
Coca cola.
But now, their slogan is generation regeneration
and converting 600,000 farms to regenerative agriculture.
And this is really interesting
because you say, well, they're doing that to be nice, no.
I'm not saying they're not nice.
I'm just saying, are they doing that to be responsible?
No, they wanna be responsible.
They're doing it because they're an old line company
they've been around for a long time.
These farms, some of them go back five generations.
They've been dealing with the farms for five generations,
these are relationships,
and these farms in south America and Africa
for cacao and coffee are hurting
and they're hurting from drought, from heat.
And so regeneration is about ensuring
the resilience and the longevity
of those relationships and their supply chain.
It's like an infrastructure bill.
Right.
If they wanna continue doing what they're doing,
They're gonna have to look at the soil
and the wellbeing of the farm lands.
Even the varieties, Arabica coffees,
they're looking at wild varieties
that can stand 5, 6, 7 degrees more heat
than the extant ones
and grafting those onto the trees
and working with agroforestry and mixed cropping
and all different ways to preserve water,
capture more water.
But what I'm saying is regeneration.
Isn't like goody two-shoes.
like we're doing this because it's the right thing to do.
It is.
But it actually is very practical.
There is a bit of a race of foot though.
Like those changes,
I'm glad to hear that they're happening
and certain large actors like that
are moving in the right direction.
But at what pace
compared to the rate at which
we're basically ridding ourselves
of the Amazonian rainforest
and dumping toxins into our waterways,
et cetera, right?
Like, is it fast enough to overtake the status quo?
I think the similarity between climate change
or global warming really is the right word.
And what we're seeing on a corporate level
is that neither are linear.
And so they're not linear systems.
And, but either is change on this level.
And I think the big change
has been the climate change was conceptual
read about it, heard about it.
We should probably do something.
Don't you think?
Yeah, okay.
Right.
Now it's experiential.
And that is the big change.
And so there's no question in my mind
that the climate movement,
whatever we should call it
will be the biggest movement in the history of humanity.
No question about it,
but because of weather,
not because there's a charismatic leader,
not because somebody is...
It's on our front doorstep.
And so the question really
isn't whether it will be the question
is how do we work together?
How will it be configured?
How will we work together?
And I think what everyone is seeing
is that we need each other.
This is not something where
somebody is gonna be a hero or heroine,
and like, hey, we did this.
It's like we need to connect.
We need to share, we need to cross fund.
We need to collaborate, we need to cooperate.
We need to support.
And you're really feeling that in the NGO community
and the volunteer community and citizen groups
in municipal groups and corporations.
You're seeing that,
let's forget all those boundaries,
so to speak.
I mean, they exist for technical,
political, financial reasons,
but we need to work together.
Forget the differences.
What unites us is far more important
than what used to divide us.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I want a snack a moment
to talk to you about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is,
most people I know actually already know
how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and lagoons into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly.
And because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is the plant power meal planner
are affordable,
all-in-one, digital platform,
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious, and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery,
and you get access to our amazing team
of nutrition coaches, seven days a week,
and many other features to learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership.
When you use the promo code,
RRHealth at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff,
people for just a $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com
promo code, RRHealth for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
What is your sense of, of where we're at now?
I mean, it's been a couple of years,
since we sat down and talked,
a lot of changes have occurred,
and a lot of things are happening on the planet.
You mentioned this report that just came out today
as a matter of fact, right?
So give us a state of the union on planetary health.
Well, the sixth assessment fund,
the intergovernmental panel on climate change
came out today.
It had been leaked,
so it was sort of being whispered about,
but it came out today and it's strong,
very, very strong.
And it said for the first time unequivocally
climate change that we are witnessing
is caused by human beings.
It always up until now,
the fifth assessment all, and going back to the first one
was equivocal.
They actually kind of left a little space there to say,
well...
And what is the organization or governing body
that puts this together?
The United nations framework on climate change,
the UN FCC,
which does the conference of the parties every year
and the 26th one will occur in Glasgow
in the first week of November.
And, but two things came out of it,
which are some good news and it oddly enough,
which is that, the science has changed.
So now we know that
as soon as we stop increasing greenhouse gases,
that is net zero emissions
that actually warming will level off right away.
It used to be that up until this assessment
that we were baking in
increasing global warming for decades if not centuries,
which kind of was a disincentive of ,
if we get it right, we're still screwed kind of thing.
And now they said, no, no.
So it's providing a very powerful incentive
for countries and companies and people
in cities to accelerate that move
towards net zero emissions.
The other thing it said though,
which is the bad news,
which is there are irreversible changes now in effect
that can't be reversed.
And one of them is melting of ice.
One of them is sea level rise.
And so there is no question that,
low lying cities like the Miamis and others
will be, Venice, unfortunately, will be flooded,
will be underwater by the end of the century or before.
And so our work is cut out for us,
but I do think that the most important thing
is that there's a hundred
and I forget the number of 180, some other countries
that are participating in this IPCC report.
And it's called consensus science,
and there's no such thing as consensus science
is evidentiary.
And what it meant was that
the Vatican or Saudi Arabia or Venezuela or China, Russia
could actually tamp down the language
and the summary report and every country in the world
signed on to this report.
No dissent.
That's powerful.
But then it becomes an issue
of translating that into action.
Yeah. And what the report said.
Yeah. Report said that politics has no excuse
from this point on.
Every country the other thing is that
every country is going to suffer.
There is no place that will be exempt.
I can think of a few American politicians
who will find an excuse.
Yes.
You know what I mean?
When they're indebted to their constituencies
and the big corporations that exist in their route,
in their respective territories,
and the lobbying efforts that go into
maintaining a certain status quo
and kind of placating the public
so that they can continue to push agendas
and legislation that are corporate favorable
and allow these bad actors to perpetuate their bad actions.
No question.
I think, however that at regeneration,
we're working with a group of marketing people
and communications people who,
by their own words,
left the dark side and went into the nonprofit world
to work with social justice, women's issues,
sex trafficking, voting issues,
and they're working with us NGOarticlegroup.org.
And what we're looking at
is what figure ground shift can be precipitated
that has occurred before.
And one of them was for example, gay shame and gay pride.
So in 2010, you could run for Congress
in the United States and basically deprecate LGBQT.
Get away with it, still get away with it.
And then get elected.
2012, the same parties said,
oh my daughter happens to be a lesbian.
You know, I'm all of a sudden it was like,
oh, well, they're okay. It's okay.
I'm okay.
Because you couldn't get elected two years later,
or at least not reliably put it that way.
I'm not saying there isn't tremendous anti LGBQT
in the conservative, in the evangelism movement.
There is of course, in other countries,
but the last month was gay pride month.
And so, multi-colored flags
and this and everywhere you saw it.
So what was that shift from shame to pride?
It was well created by the community itself. Okay.
So the same thing holds true with climate,
which is that has been marked by shame,
by the way, guilt, fear, threat, blame,
that hasn't worked,
and it's made people numb.
It's made people tune out.
It has created antipathies,
like fossil fuel workers,
who work at Chevron or some feel like,
they're being blamed and so forth.
And so what is the figure ground shift
where people can feel that we are together
and we all can make a difference
in not just again,
by your cold water in your washing machine better.
I mean, by coming together,
and the ways in which people have always come together,
that's we are social beings.
We're very social.
And so that's what we're looking at right now,
which is what is it that will bring us together
around climate?
And what brings us together
is that when you start to parse the distinct solutions,
even though they're systems they're connected
is that they better life for everyone.
They make a better life.
So that if you looked at them
in the absence of climate science or extreme weather,
and said, good, not good.
Should we do it? Not do it?
You wanna do every one of them,
every one of them.
And I think what regeneration,
the point it tries to make is
that we have focused for so long
on this idea that there's a small select,
intelligent, informed finance group of people
who are gonna solve the problem.
And we've used the term future existential threat
like this is a future existential threat
over and over and over and over,
like, you should do something cause,
and that doesn't work and never has worked.
And what regeneration is saying
is that the solutions that address global warming
actually address meeting current human needs.
And what we've got to do
is direct ourselves to each other.
There's 4.1 billion people who wake up every morning.
And the only thing they can think about
is current human needs, their needs.
It could be food, it could be income,
it could be a job.
It could be safety.
It could be food security back to food,
getting the kids to school,
getting them in school, affording books.
I mean, it goes on and on.
This is what the bulk of humanity wakes up with
every morning.
They are not gonna be active in the climate movement.
And we don't need quote
people who are really trying to better their own lives
to be active in the climate movement.
But they do need renewable energy.
They do need electricity,
they do need clean water.
They do need better farming techniques.
They do need cleaner food.
They do all these things that are synonymous
with actually reversing global warming,
actually reverses human suffering as well.
Promoting equity for all.
And that's a big part of the book,
this idea of human rights
and social justice and education and empowering women,
because you have to raise the floor
on people's sort of daily subsistence levels
to create a situation in which
they're not only benefiting
from these changes that are being made,
but then well taken care of enough
so that they can become part of this movement as well.
They, by de facto just by leading their lives,
they become part of it.
And in Drawdown one of my regrets about Drawdown
is that we had educating girls as a solution,
well solution.
And then we actually looked at it in terms of carbon.
That is if we actually provided schooling
for the 145 million girls who are not in school,
who could be,
and what effect that would have on carbon emissions.
And that goes to population deforestation,
all these sorts of things.
In this one, we didn't do that.
And what I said is that actually
most of these young women are in countries
where they need to have a higher carbon footprint.
They need more, they're in poverty
and we and the privilege north or wherever,
shouldn't be looking at them for changing their life.
So that there's less greenhouse gas emissions.
We should be looking at educating these girls
as a human right.
And it's just a human right.
And stop there, don't go any further.
And we really have to look at ourselves,
the top 10% of income earners in the world.
And that's over 38,000 puts you in the top 10%
are responsible for 46 to 50%
of all greenhouse gas emissions.
So we have to work out it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So would you change that section in Drawdown,
you could rewrite it.
Yeah. Yeah.
The there's a new ed there.
They're going to stick to it,
but I'm not. That's why I did.
This has always attended to be the SQL to Drawdown.
I don't know what they're gonna do with that,
but the importance is to start to see again,
I say anything if you want to understand poverty,
look to see who's benefiting, right?
That's a recurring loop.
Nobody wants to be poor.
And also poverty doesn't want to be fixed.
It wants to fix itself.
Explain that a little bit.
It's called Pride, dignity, purpose,
and people who are poor don't want a handout
Don't want, shiploads of surplus grain
to be dumped on the shores of some country and passed out.
I mean, they may need it at that moment
because of some sort of food shortage,
but that doesn't solve anything
because it's not addressing the conditions
that caused it in the first place.
And so all of regeneration
is about creating the conditions for self-organization
that's what your body does.
That's what every living system does.
It creates the conditions for self-organization.
And so when we think about solving an intractable problem,
like global warming, oh man, it's impossible.
What can we do?
And look all these mega institutions and political stupidity
and ignorance and so forth.
But if we step back and say, well,
what are the conditions that create
self-organization or self abnegation?
That is that destroy that
then that's where we wanna go.
And that is the source of change.
I mean, regeneration is innate to every living system.
It's innate to us.
We regenerate every day,
we practice it every day.
We do it with our bodies.
We do with our dog,
we do it with our children.
We do with our friends.
We do with our mom,
we do whatever.
We are actively trying to improve
the life of others.
It's so human, our 30 trillion cells,
we generate every nanosecond
or we wouldn't be having this conversation, right?
Right. And they do it without our intervention.
So planetarily,
this is a combination of getting out of the way
and allowing things to heal themselves
and repair themselves.
And on top of that, certain,
sort of strategic surgical human interventions
to promote that regeneration
so that it can become self perpetuating.
Yeah. It's not getting out of the way so much.
It's not thinking hierarchically
that you know what needs to be done.
It's a matter of doing,
not knowing what needs to be done.
And then that's what we've done up to now,
this needs to be done.
And all of this needs to be done.
This needs to be done,
that the people wanna heal themselves.
They wanna heal the society,
the places they live in,
and they wanna heal the land.
I was once in the Northwest,
this is years ago now.
But when, there are hanging spotted owls
in the back of pickup trucks,
cause there loggers and the newcomers
is so to speak of from the cities
where just at pun intended,
I guess, loggerheads, and fighting.
'cause the loggers felt that these city slickers
or these liberals were tying to make them jobless, right?
And I remember being in a city, was a town really,
and to talk about the future.
So I speak and the aisle is aisle on this side
was all the loggers and the guys of the plaid shirts.
And pickup trucks on this side was,
the environmentalists and the conservationists
and the people who really wanted to take care of everything.
But I just ask simple questions and I said,
how many people here want their rivers to have more fish
or less fish in 30, 40 years?
And everybody raised their hand like more,
how many people want cleaner water, dirty water,
and all always went out, not today,
but 30, 40 years raise your hand.
How many people would want their children if you have them
to be able to stay here and get living wage jobs
and stay close to the family,
rather than having to go to the city?
Everybody raised their hand.
How many people want hunting to get better or worse?
Everybody raise their hand.
How many...
just went on and on.
I said, you're all in agreement.
You agree on everything you want.
So the question is,
instead of talking about what you don't agree about
is to work backwards from where you agree.
But then it has to be about
finding a way forward
that isn't a threat or a perceived threat
to people's livelihoods.
Of course.
Yeah, of course.
Absolutely.
So there has to be a just transition for coworkers,
has to be a just transition for fossil fuel workers.
There has to be compassionate.
There has to be care.
There has to be acknowledgement
that these people are good people
and they have families and they care about the world
just as much as you do,
they care about it a different way.
They've been taught in a different way.
They think in a different way.
That doesn't make them bad.
Doesn't make you good.
And so absolutely.
And that's what it means for us to come together.
But the most powerful way you come together
is to listen not to know.
And so again, if you go at the climate as a know it all
I know you don't listen up, it's gonna fail.
Right.
But if you look at it
from the point of view of the inherent values,
that we almost all uphold
in terms of what it means to be safe,
to be a family,
to have children, to not have children.
If that's your choice,
to be a part of your community,
to be respectful, we're in agreement
and what the world wants is to me,
and this is my belief
is that we've created such meaningless employment
for the bulk of humanity.
I mean, they know it's meaningless,
it's repetitive,
repetitive, excuse me.
It is kind of,
it doesn't challenge them in terms of intelligence.
It doesn't pay well,
it's in poor working conditions.
I'll give an example.
I calculated how much a worker would make in 1800
and the dark satanic hubs in mills of England.
And these are textile mills.
It's a penny an hour.
Okay
And today's dollars
because the penny was related to golden silver.
Then it's 30 cents.
It was 30 cents an hour.
At that time in today's dollars.
The average pay today for garment workers
in the world is 30 cents an hour.
So, in 220 years we haven't changed the pay scale
for garment workers at all.
So what people are looking for
is purpose and meaning and dignity.
And there could be no more meaningful
work in the world today,
which is to restore life on earth.
So the book is very much
about all the different, fascinating ways
that that can happen.
And it has a demonstrative important impact
on reversing global warming,
as opposed to, oh, get solar,
get an EV, do this too.
I'm not saying you shouldn't do that if you can,
but for most of humanity, those are not options.
And so we have to look at it from a much broader,
more enlarging, more upholding way
that relates to what people can do.
And the other thing I think it's important to do
is to stop thinking that this is what you ought to do.
These are the top 10 solutions.
You should focus on those.
That was another thing that Drawdown did inadvertently
was his to rank all the solutions by impact.
And then people said,
all looked at the top 10 or the top 15
and not to say that they aren't proportionally impactful.
They are,
but actually the most important things for you to do
are the ones that light you up,
where you just get excited.
Nobody wants to wake up in the morning,
and says I can't wait to mitigate today.
Yeah. That was a similar message
in Margaret's book,
it was called like fighting the climate crisis
or something like that.
I don't know if you read that book.
It's a good one.
But I have her on the show.
Yeah.
And it's just how it's all about, like,
how do you get people plugged into this?
And you got to get them excited.
And I think because we're so divorced
from the natural cycle of life
and the earth beneath our feet,
finding a way to reconnect with that,
that meets a certain person's enthusiasm
is a great way forward.
And it shifts the lens away from the idea
that climate change is happening to us.
To this idea that I know you've spoken about,
which is the idea that climate change is happening for us.
Like where is the opportunity here
to reconfigure everything and create
a completely different way of living
for the vast majority of people who are so disengaged
from the natural environment.
Exactly. And the thing is if you...
I mean, there's solutions there like beavers.
I know I love that.
I didn't know all that about beaver, right?
It's like, if that excites you and it does,
by the way, are people just love beavers.
They studied them, they work.
And they tried to,
I didn't realize how many beavers there were.
There are a lot of beavers
and who trapped them in the cities
and then not to take them where they will do more good,
upstream, so to speak
in mountainous areas and so forth.
But if you doing something that just you love to do,
you're very likely then to be open to other things
that need to be done
because now you're starting to see yourself
as an integral part,
an effective integral part
to restarting life on earth,
which is really what reversing global warming is about.
It's about restoring life on earth.
We've taken as much as we should,
long time ago actually, we've passed that limit.
And so again, you know,
I define regeneration
as putting life at the center very act and decision.
I mean, that's what regeneration is.
And so looking through that lens,
looking through that...
seeing the world that way
then allows you to basically reflect,
on what it is you're doing
and what it is that you're a part of this being done
and how it's being done.
And it doesn't mean leaving it or quitting.
It means can we change that?
Can we change that?
Have you thought about this?
Is this possibility?
Is there this way,
can we, it's really about doing what you can in place,
as opposed to finding some other place in the world
where you can make a difference.
you're most effective where people know and respect you.
Yeah.
When you say the word regeneration
immediately what comes to mind for me
is soil regeneration.
And, there's been a massive explosion
in terms of people's awareness
and care with respect to
how we're treating our soils.
And, you can credit our friend Reiland
for all the beautiful work that he's doing
with kiss the ground and the documentary that he made,
John and Molly Chester and the biggest little farm,
like there are pieces of really powerful mass media
that I think are shifting the paradigm
and helping people to better understand
this piece of the puzzle.
But the book really canvases
a much broader definition of what regeneration is
and you break it down into all these different categories.
You've got oceans and forests
and wilding and land and people and cities
and food and energy and industry.
And within that,
all these subcategories
where people are doing amazing things.
And you kind of explain why this is important,
how you can get involved
the new kind of operating modalities
that are helping to heal the planet
in these various capacities.
And I think if you page through the book,
you're gonna find that thing
that's gonna make you enthusiastic,
whether it's beavers or, urban gardening or whatever it is.
And what was interesting is
there were so many things in here.
Like, I feel like I have a pretty good grip
on this general landscape,
but there was a lot in here
that I didn't know anything about
some pretty interesting things in here.
Like I wrote down a few of them,
like the Azzola Fern was one that I didn't know much about.
Maybe you can explain that a little bit,
trophic cascades, what are these things?
They are and when you first see them on the page going,
what does this have to do with...?
I'm worried about the future, my children,
and he's talking about a trophic cascade.
He's talking about the beavers.
Yeah.
Same with beavers.
Azzola Fern is a Fern and it floats,
it lives on the surface of the water.
It metabolizes nitrogen from the air.
It fixes nitrogen from the air.
So it doubles every two and a half days
if it's cold, in two days,
if it's warm, in three days,
but approximately it doubles.
And it is rich in omega threes,
which is unusual for a plant
and needed by this omega six world.
We live in a junk food
and it makes the oil and it sequesters carbon.
And the reason we know that,
not that any plant doesn't do that,
every plant does, but there was an Azolla event,
49 million years ago.
And at that time,
that PPM of CO2 was 25,000.
It was pretty hot and there was no ice in the Arctic
and it was a freshwater lens.
And you had these Azzola it's called the Azolla event,
but there's all events where in the summer it would be
covered with Azzola.
And then in the cooler part in the winter,
it would die and sink to the bottom.
And then that happened.
And within a relatively short geological time,
it went down to from 25 to 6,000 PPM.
And it is subscribed to Azzola, the presence of Azzola.
Well Azolla can still do that. No reds.
It can still sequester things very, very rapidly.
So whether they're in lakes or wetlands,
or even rivers and so forth or ponds,
Azzola can sequester carbon,
you can harvest it.
You can feed it to animals, chickens, rabbits, goats.
Right, it's like a very nutrient rich
Very nutrient rich,
you can put it in your salad.
It's delicious, right?
So, you can make oil out of it.
You can have omega-3 eggs.
If you're an egg eater
and you want your eggs to be much more nutritious.
And the rate of carbon sequestration,
is quite extraordinary.
And you could even,
although I'm sure a lot of people wouldn't wanna do it.
You could even put it in a river
and then like the Missouri going into the Mississippi
and then, it doubles and gets bigger and bigger and bigger
then you could have it taken out.
You're taking it out all the way down the Mississippi.
And then when it gets to the golf, it dies.
And it goes down to the bottom.
The oil that's being drilled for
in the Arctic today is due to Azzola Fern.
Is it really?
Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
Wow.
And so the interesting thing about it,
though if it's in a river
is cleaning the river up
from both hydrogen and phosphorus it'll.
So right now what you have in the Missouri,
Mississippi is runoff.
And as it gets to the Gulf, it creates this huge dead zone.
So you all go dead zone, feeding, algal, blooms, you know,
and Sargaso sea for that matter,
you're going into Tulum in Mexico.
And so Azolla cleans that up.
And so the possibilities with Azzola Fern are extraordinary.
So why aren't we doing that?
Well...
Couldn't we create a massive reservoirs also,
and just harvest this stuff
while we're sequestering carbon.
Hey, when I did Drawdown,
we talked about asparagosis tax performance,
which is this type of seaweed
that if fed in very small amounts,
one, 2% to ruminants, like cows obviously
that would reduce methane emissions,
from their digestion by 89%.
Well, that was four plus years ago.
And it's happening.
In other words,
there are a dozen companies now
that did not exist at that time
had patents, they have this they're competing,
they're cultivating it
or trying to also they're actually selling it
is being used and so forth.
So it took a very short time.
I think Azzola is in the same place
where we didn't discover it obviously
that's not what we're saying,
but I think it might come to a broader understanding
and awareness now,
so that people will do something
that and there's so many imaginative ways
that you can use it.
And it has so many positive and beneficial effects.
In our kind of dualistic way of looking at things though,
I'm imagining like,
we think this is some panacea
and we'd dump it in the Mississippi.
And then there's some downstream,
ecological ecosystem implication that we're not foreseeing.
Yeah. And it's invasive,
but it can't invade running water
because the water keeps going one direction.
So, but I'm sure there might be.
But if you do it at your farm,
at your own reservoir, at your pond,
that you sat, whatever it is, it's yours.
And so there is nothing,
there is no downside from that,
but there's always got to look at these things
very carefully.
Right.
We use a river analogy just to give people
a sense of scale of undammed rivers.
If there was an Azzola,
what's it called?
I don't know,
it's not a company or whatever
that was working with the state or the country,
or hydrologists and everybody,
they were all working together.
You could be pulling off so much carbon,
so much food.
I mean, you'd be replacing the soy
and the crap that's being groaned,
that's causing the runoff with the Azzola,
which is really extraordinary.
Right. Cause it's a bio fertilizer,
but it's also a great animal feed.
Yeah. You can work it into the soil.
You can work it into the animal...
And it grows like crazy.
It grows like crazy.
So, it's like hemp,
it's like this crazy multipurpose plant
that we've overlooked.
Yeah. What's wrong with this picture.
It's hard to find out what's wrong with it.
Wow.
Yeah.
The other mindblower was this idea
of rainmakers microbes in the sky.
Yeah.
So walk me through that.
Sure will.
It's been known for some time that
like coastal development,
like in Spain, the whole Costa Brava,
the whole coast was developed in the last 30 plus years.
I mean, it was Mediterranean coast beaches,
and then it just got overrun by hotels and condos basically,
for northerners wanting to come in
own something in the south, in the winter.
But what also happened
is that the rainfall patterns changed completely inland
the summer rainfall.
And they know now why,
because those structures all on the Southern coast of Spain
destroyed all the wetlands.
And so we have this idea
that the long rain cycle
is the cycle comes from the oceans,
goes inland drops main,
there's a short water cycle,
which is the rain comes up on the land,
moves and drops.
And there's a story, not a story,
but a scientific study that was done in Africa,
in Malawi of tea plantations in a specific valley.
And the study came about
because it had the highest concentration of hail in Africa.
And the question was why?
I mean, it just didn't make sense,
why here and not the next valley over
or in some other country for that matter.
And one of the scientists
who studied it was aware that
we used to think the water nucleates on dust.
So in other words, how does a gas like, become a liquid?
Well, it attaches,
it has to attach to something
that's called nucleation
water attaches to water really easily,
but it doesn't attach to other things so easily
and gas.
It doesn't become water.
And so we just assumed for many years
there's a lot of dust in the atmosphere.
Now we know there's killer amount of bacteria
in the atmosphere and diverse bacteria.
So in Malawi, he actually took the hail,
melted it and then basically looked at the bacteria
that was in there and sequenced it
and discovered that the bacteria
that was predominant in the hail
was specific to the tea plants in that valley.
And only in that valley.
in other words, the tea and the agriculture
was creating the precipitation.
So the atmosphere is literally a microbiome
that's populated by the plant life on the ground.
Absolutely. And always has been.
And the diversity of the plant life,
the quality of that plant life
dictates what that atmospheric microbiome is.
And in turn plays a large role
in the rainfall, the extent of the rainfall,
the quality of the rainfall.
Just like the Sahara desert,
which is now the opposite,
completely dry dust storms come off the Sahara.
You can see them.
I mean, from satellites across the Atlantic ocean
and they go south into the Amazon
and the rainfall the Amazon benefits hugely
from the dust from the Sahara.
And so we are just discovering that,
but science is discovering
these extraordinary relationships.
And what we do know
is that the temperature that we experience
80% of that is caused by the hydrosphere,
not by the atmosphere.
And that is to say that hydrosphere
is it can be the clouds,
but it can be the fog,
but it can be really the transpiration of the plants
and the soil around us.
And that can lower surface temperature
by one to two degrees centigrade,
and sometimes more and so forth.
So the other aspect of that is that
our deforestation, our over-grazing
and our agricultural methodology,
that industrial agriculture has desiccated the land.
You're a runner.
You know what happens when you get too dry?
I mean, it is, you're in dangerous territory,
first of all and you can't function well,
the earth has been desiccated.
And so what regenerative practices do,
whether they're animals grazing,
whether it's aforestation, whether it's agroforestry,
whether it's regenerative agriculture
actually is they change the composition of the soil
because they start to sequester and place more carbon.
And that carbon is food for microbes
and virus and protozoa, et cetera.
And that they start to eat each other.
And they form globulin,
which is kind of a humic acid and so forth.
And it changes the structure of the soil
so that when it does rain,
whether a lot or a little,
the soil can retain the water,
soil, retains the water,
then it's going to transpire the water
when it gets hot.
And it's gonna cool plants grow better
when it's cooler in the summer,
than when it's hot.
So you're getting this amazing virtuous cycles
by basically restoring degraded land.
And there is an estimation of two to 3 billion hectares.
That's five to seven and a half billion acres of land
on earth that can be restored
and not just the quest of carbon,
but probably more importantly, it's a quest of water.
Water yeah.
Yeah.
That was one of the profound things that I noticed
when I visited John and Molly Chester's farm,
which have you visited?
Oh, you haven't been there ?
Oh you gotta go,
it's just down the street.
I know.
Next time you're in LA you gotta see it
I mean, they they're in your book.
So I know you're very familiar
with everything that they're doing,
but when you're on their land,
you're kind of at a high point,
you can see the other farms
that are surrounding that farm.
And the difference is pretty dramatic.
And just the colors alone,
comparatively to the neighboring farms
that are farming conventionally is unbelievable.
And one of the things that they were telling me
was when you get the rains,
the rare rains in the winter time here in California,
the water doesn't run off.
Like you're not getting all this flooding
and all the other problems
that these other farms are having.
Like the water stays there.
Yeah.
And it almost creates its own like little micro climate
around the farm.
It does.
And the thing is like,
again people, there's been a tendency
to talk about the big solutions,
they revolve around energy,
of course, cause it's 76, 80% different numbers
of the greenhouse gas emissions today
are from the combustion of coal gas and oil.
So of course, if we don't do that,
we're goners no question about it,
but that then has caused us to overlook the importance
of what the Chesters are doing,
what regenerative land does,
what the degenerative land does
what agroforestry, reforestation
managed grazing does.
I mean, those are just as important,
and so that again, goes back to this idea.
Well, I was just restoring,
2000 acres in the middle of the Australian
not desert but so forth,
but it's somewhere in Australia. Yeah.
That's really important.
There is, as opposed to thinking, well,
it doesn't really make a difference.
It makes a huge difference.
And those are the differences,
all around the world.
And I guess my question is,
how do we get that going?
Right?
I mean that's the $64,000 question, right?
Like I would suspect that most farmers
would rather be farming
in the way that John and Molly are farming
than the way that they're currently farming.
Yes.
But the gap from status quo
to the situation that John and Molly are in
is pretty vast.
You have to create some kind of incentivization
or transitionary situation
to allow those people to free themselves
from the kind of tyrannical situation that they're in,
where they're in this
basically an indentured servitude relationship
with big agricultural firms
that compel them to do things in a certain way
and allow them to transition.
Because, if you get anything from that documentary,
it's how long it took
to get it to a situation
where now it's semi self perpetuating.
There were some lean, very difficult years
where most people would have bailed
and gone back to the old ways.
So you have to create an economic buffer
for these people and an on-ramp.
The way to understand industrial ag versus say,
not opposed to, but compared to regenerative ag is simple
and industrial agriculture started
or really got going in the middle of the 19th century
when chemical fertilizers were invented
and then got nos on steroids.
Once the Haber Bosch method
of creating nitrates was early 20th century.
And so industrial ag basically feeds plants, NPK,
and then the macro nutrients it needs to grow.
And when it first started to be used in the 19th century,
there was a lot of bad farming in Germany and Europe.
There was hunger issues there really were.
And all of a sudden you put this powder on the field
and these bright green plants
that are taller than the ones you didn't get
and go, hey, we're onto something.
I mean, this is cool.
And it just got better and better quote unquote,
in a sense of phosphorus and potassium,
and pretty soon that was how you grew plants.
You could grow more of it.
That yields are greater, et cetera.
It always takes time.
When you do that to realize
that the plants are weaker
because regenerative ag actually doesn't feed plants,
it feeds soil.
And for the 400 million years that plants have been here
soil has always fed the plants.
And so in essentially industrial ag
is putting plants on an IV drip,
that's what it's doing.
And you take the drip away and the plants suffer
because the soil has been degraded
and it's really holding the plant up.
It's not feeding the plant.
So there is that transition.
There's no question about it.
And we do need a way to support farmers,
because the reason I have never met a regen ag farmer,
and I've met quite a number
who did it because it was a right thing to do.
Now, you say, whoa, why did they do it?
They did it because they hit the wall.
It's the same as people's health.
What people don't change their diet
because it's a right thing to do.
They change it cause they hit the wall and said,
this is not working at all.
And then they turn to people
to functional medicine, to you, to whatever.
I mean, they turn into their,
wait a minute.
I don't know what to do.
And so the farmers I've met,
basically hit the wall.
They were running out of money
and they were feeling this squeeze
between producing commodities,
having the prices out of their control
and being part of an over-producing system,
then suppress prices and their costs were going up
because the soil was getting poor, poor,
turning into dirt as has been said,
and then it needed more and more and more input.
And it needed pesticides
because the plants were so weak,
the bugs were eating it
and then it needed glyphosate
because the weeds could out-compete the plant.
And pretty soon you have basically modern ag.
But again, as I said earlier,
that was, farmers could see
that that degenerative road ended,
they could see the ending,
it was called basically the bank saying
pay up or we're gonna take all your equipment.
Right, right. Yeah.
And that's right.
So the biggest fact that
the biggest change in the farming community
on regen ag is caused by farmers
that farmers talking to farmers.
Right.
That's what I was thinking
like pivoting from that blame and shame,
modus operandi into empowerment and engagement.
It's those farmers who have made that transition,
who are the ones
who are gonna be able to communicate
to the other farmers there.
They're not gonna want to hear it from you,
or let alone me.
I mean, God forbid, so yeah,
like creating community around that,
that's supportive and empowering
to helping people make that transition.
But also on top of that
systems that are conducive to that
being an economic viability.
But there are things happening
where the demand for regenerative to duly produce
seeds, grains, and obviously meat as well,
but are increasing faster than production.
Sure.
And so farmers are seeing a premium,
their inputs are going down,
their costs are going down,
but actually the income is going up
and you see 10X differences in profit per acre
for regen farmers.
And as Gay Brown famously said,
he said, I got tired of basically signing
the front of the check.
And now I sign the back of the check,
notice it shifted from an expense to income,
and you don't go back from that.
And so now there's companies and processes
and techniques and satellites,
and there is a lot of support now
being created for regen ag in its true form.
And it's being also done
in some dubious forms as well.
Yeah.
And yet, I just,
I was out of town the other day
and just i was in an airplane yesterday
and you look down
and you don't see a lot of regenerative farms.
You see giant swaths of square and round parcels
Headed irrigation.
Yeah.
Yeah, so where are we
in terms of that becoming
like reaching some kind of inflection point with this?
I don't know. I don't know.
I know that like the big,
big companies are pivoting on this.
They have the same questions
which is, how do we make the transition?
They don't,
how did their farmers make the transition?
And how's the brushes doing with rice
general mills is trying to do with oats.
But so many,
like the clothing companies now
are basically looking for regenerative fiber,
primarily cotton, but other fibers as well.
So you're seeing a supply demand dance.
The consumer demand.
I mean, I feel like Gen Z,
the younger generation,
they're up to speed on this stuff.
And they're much more conscious
about their consumer choices than our generation.
Much more, I mean, when I started Erewhon,
we are mom out all the time about you hippies
you wanna feed the world organically,
but we industrial ag have we take care of the children,
we have a world of feed.
You guys are sort of, self-indulgent almost narcissistic,
and you're wanting things without chemicals and pesticides,
and now I don't know how big the industry is
it's so big that you can't get enough organic food
in the United States yet.
But the same thing is regen is not gonna go through that
because you're seeing
every major agricultural company in the world,
Syngenta and Cartiva and Monsanto buyer and ADM and Cargill
moving to regeneration.
Now, I mean,
keep your tongue firmly in your cheek on that one,
because I feel like there's some co-ops going on there
in terms of the term and the word,
but as Franklin Roosevelt once said
that sometimes the way you start telling the truth
is by being a hypocrite at first.
And so who knows where that's gonna go,
but you do see indigo ag,
which is all about regenerative farming
from the get-go and not about chemicals,
kind of like the opposite of a Monsanto
doing really, really well.
Working with not only with regenerative farmers,
but in terms of, metrics
in terms of measuring carbon and de commodification,
that is connecting farmers directly to the buyers
and getting the farmers out of the commodities business,
where no matter how well you do,
you're still, the price is the same for everybody.
And so that has to happen.
So that regenerative farmers can get a premium
and that the food companies that buy that
have a story and a narrative,
that means something to Gen Z
and everybody else who cares.
Yeah. The story narrative piece, I think is big.
I think most companies these days need something,
there has to be a genuine, authentic aspect
of doing business.
Oh yeah. I mean,
and I think they recognize that
and I mean, we'll see what happens,
but I think that we're in a period of tumultuous change.
Some of it is threatening for sure and daunting.
But I get the sense in the business community
that the old ways are over.
I really do.
And I'm not praising anybody.
I'm not to think finally business gets it.
And I'm not saying that either,
if anybody doesn't get it,
I would say, it's the investors.
They still want to put their money
where they can get the highest return
and the earth doesn't work that way.
Right?
Yeah. I mean, banking is a whole section in the book
about that.
Yeah, yeah.
Where do you see the role of hydroponics in all of this?
I mean, obviously this is that's growing plants
in a manner that's divorced
from the soil conversation all together.
I suspect there's a great place for that
in urban centers or places where there isn't soil,
but how does that fit into the idea of regeneration?
Well, it's interesting
because plants suffer.
that is to say,
that they suffer because it gets too hot.
It's too much sun, insects.
They suffer for a lack of nutrient, for example.
So they put the roots down deeper,
the complexity of the taste
and the phyto nutrients
that are in plants are actually due to stress.
So plants that are stressed are more nutritious.
Right.
When you do hydroponics,
you're actually going back to industrial ag,
which is, you're doing
your as an IV drip into the roots.
It's fine if you just Basil for salad or watercress
or something for greenery in cities,
the idea that that's going to produce nutritious food,
I think is faulty
because we have an nutritious food now everywhere.
And we have food that comes from industrial ag.
Both, whether it's row crops
or in vegetables or whether it's in grains and seeds.
And we have measured,
we can measure the difference
in the phytonutrients and minerals
or the lack of minerals that are in these foods.
So we haven't been able to invent a way
to make a really super nutritious food without soil yet.
And I don't think we ever will.
What about the carbon sequestration piece of it?
Of what?
Meaning that if you're an urban centers
and you don't have soil,
but you have all these hydroponic gardens everywhere,
is that moving the needle at all
in terms of probably carbon?
Probably not. I think it's...
at the same time,
we do wanna localize food production.
We do wanna bring food into the city,
into the peri urban areas, right around the city.
And that does involve greenhouses
that does involve all sorts of really ingenious techniques,
to extend the season and to produce crops that people want.
And there's nothing wrong
with the crops that are grown hydroponically in terms of,
but just not the idea
that somehow that's going to replace the foods we need.
They just won't,
but it can produce very fresh and tasty.
Like I said, parsley and basil and watercress and lettuces
and things like that,
which are not really, I mean, the major source
of our nurture or nutrients.
Let's talk about energy.
Yeah.
Why can't we get wind power?
Like just rocking out everywhere.
Like what are the impediments to really scaling that?
Cause it seems to me
that's the most viable best solution at the moment.
I think the major impediment is sighting.
In other words,
people don't want
people generally don't live
where there is the high wind regimes.
The Midwest is the winds blowing all the time, almost,
and so their farmers love them,
with their corn, they have two crops,
kilowatts and corn.
I think that the major obstacle is offshore wind.
In other words, sighting offshore wind.
And I think Heinrich, Starzl
has Danish engineer has solved the problem.
And he was the...
when he was young,
he started filling out with wind turbines.
And the three blade configuration that you see today
on the big turbines, he invented that
and a farming supply company called Bestos
heard about him.
Because at that time farms had windmills.
My grandfather's farm had a windmill on it for water.
Right.
And they bought the rights to his design.
And Bestos is the biggest wind turbine company
in the world today, 13 billion a year.
And Stossel has invented a floating platform.
They can go out far into the sea
to areas where they won't interfere
with people's view scape,
where there's a lot of land, so to speak,
but it's not land is water.
And I think that
that is going to come in at a price
that is also less expensive than coal gas and oil
and wind already is by the way,
the new wind farm installations,
solar is also lower cost
than fossil fuel electrical generation.
And I just think it's a matter of,
I don't know, maybe two, three years,
cause they're testing them right now.
They're floating them.
And Stossel is such an amazing engineer.
I mean, his track record is extraordinary
and when he does something, it tends to work.
And somebody said, well,
when he started this project over the flooding wind farms,
Studies said, what if we can't afford it?
And his response is
we can't afford not to.
So I think there is that
again that inflection point where we're going right now,
which is a week quibbling
over a half a cent per kilowatt hour,
that the coal is cheaper
than it's not,
but I mean are we gonna like,
get, I mean, it's cheap,
let's buy it. Let's do it, end of subject.
Yeah.
It just seems like there should be massive,
wind farms offshore and then like sort of,
areas of the planet
where there's tons of wind
and low population density
and throughout the desert solar farms everywhere.
There will be.
I think there will be.
The interesting thing about
we think of things like death spiral,
something, there's also other types of spirals,
which is disruption spirals.
And we're in a disruption spiral with wind and solar,
renewable energy.
Which is it's cost is going down.
As this cost goes down, demand goes up.
As demand goes up, demand for fossil fuel goes down
as that declines, the cost goes up okay?
For fossil fuels.
It doesn't go down.
It goes up if you use less of something
than you're producing.
And so as the demand goes up,
it attracts more investment.
More capital wants to go
where something is growing of course.
So the cost of capital goes down.
investment in the fossil fuels,
which is peaking and declining.
The cost of capital is going up.
So these are, this is a disruption spiral.
This is going to accelerate the rate of acceleration
that we're seeing in renewables.
And most of the projections about solar and wind
or renewable have been linear, the IEA,
the International Energy Agency,
the world bank, similarly McKinsey as well.
And last year they admitted that they had been wrong
every single year for 19 years.
By undershooting it?
Yeah, absolutely.
Every single year.
Absolutely you could count on them,
to get it wrong.
Every one of those institutions.
And they did on batteries as well
storage for EBS and for...
and so I think we're on a threshold
where we're going to be surprised
at the rate of growth in solar and wind.
And the only thing that is going to not prevent it
because it's simply a capital formation
and capital wants to go to it
because it really pencils out.
And the demand is there.
A big piece with energy on this quest
to electrify everything,
which is a big point that you make in the book
is storage, right?
So we have these batteries,
batteries are improving.
They're growing in their capacity to hold storage,
but they also degenerate
and they require tons of mineral inputs,
which of course have downstream impacts on the planet.
Like there is no perfect panacea situation here
if we improve our batteries
and then everybody's got batteries for everything,
we're pivoting away from drilling and fracking
to just mining,
which is what we're already seeing.
And we're seeing a disproportionate amount of that
we're seeing like China really capitalize on that
in a big way right now
that's creating kind of a geopolitical imbalance
in terms of that certain economy is functioning.
Yeah. There are things like neodymium
that are integral to magnets
and the magnets are integral
to power generation and wind turbines.
And the rare earth monopoly is almost China,
not quiet really, but they really,
56 or 58% of Lithium has come from China.
And so they definitely have control on that.
What I'm seeing is that
in the like storage area
where it's primarily lithium ion,
and there are some,
I guess what I'm saying is that
there's a whole bunch of innovators
circling around that one solid state batteries,
carbon-based batteries no lithium
and startups that are brilliant
and are pointing to material use
and storage capacity and cost reductions
that we've seen in every single area of energy
on the renewable side.
Nobody thought that solar or wind would be this cheap
ever not in your wildest imagination.
Did anybody think that,
you'd be installing solar
for less than 2 cents, a kilowatt hour
in the Saudi Arabia of all places.
I mean, but they're doing it at a profit.
I mean, it's not like subsidized.
And so the same thing holds true for storage,
which is that I don't think we're locked in
to the technologies that we're using right now.
And I think you're going to see on this storage side,
I think you're gonna see techniques,
technologies basically
that are still gonna use minerals
and minerals that are ubiquitous and easy to get
as opposed to Bolivia or in the Atacama desert
or things that are more sparse
or not so well distributed.
That's encouraging.
Yeah.
I feel like the progress that's being made
with batteries is similar
to the history of the microchip, right?
It's accelerating very quickly.
And every year, EVs are coming out
and the battery life's getting better
and better and better and et cetera,
like it does feel like that's getting figured out.
Yeah, it is.
And we're in a huge disruptive cycle
in a good sense.
I mean, we're the disruptive cycle
that we're this causing it is climate,
but there is technologically a rate of disruption
that's occurring that is hold on to your hat.
The rate of change,
the players, the university's engineers,
the technologists, the entrepreneurs,
the capital formation is extraordinary.
And so nothing that we,
I think are projecting in the future
is going to live up to what will actually happen
is gonna be more, it's gonna be better.
That doesn't mean by the way, though,
that we should all have an electric car,
I mean, we should live in cities,
we don't need a car at all, right?
I mean...
The 15 minute city.
The 15 minute city, We should,
this isn't...
I feel like sometimes when you listen to
some companies or some people,
so some politicians
that the idea is to fix it
so that we can just continue to grow our economy bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger.
And we just have to get rid of
this nasty little problem called climate.
And actually...
That's kidding in a way.
That's just sort of annoyingly getting in the way
of economic growth.
We've got to get all right,
get all...
but the alignment isn't with nature,
the alignment is with GDP.
How can we get this?
And that's a very much a JP Morgan,
that's very much an investment banking way
of seeing the world,
which is okay.
It is, how can we make money doing this
and doing this and doing that.
But what's underlying that
is like the business as usual scenarios
that are used by the IAA
and the world bank and the APCC
basically project an economy
that's two and a half times bigger by 2050
and seven times bigger by 2100.
And that is just ridiculous.
It's so absurd to think that we can 2X, 7X, 5X, whatever,
where we are today
in terms of throughput and economy.
I mean, and so really part of the innovation
has to be, how can we do more with less?
How can we fulfill our needs as human beings?
And we have needs,
and in a way that actually lowers our footprint,
not just our carbon footprint,
but our whole footprint.
And so, I don't see that
really coming into the conversation yet
in terms of regeneration.
Right.
How long can the economy continue to multiply at that level?
Like, is this going to go on ad infinitum?
Is there any conversation about...?
That's the ultimate unsustainability?
Absolutely.
And every price of every share
with some exceptions on stock exchanges
is based on assumed and projected rate of growth.
And there are stocks that just pay dividends,
like pipeline, just pay out.
So there's a few,
but 99% are based on growth
and imagined projected,
based on the past, based on, pipe dreams, whatever.
It is weird that success is predicated
this idea of growth.
Like why is it not okay
to just have a business that does fine
and pays its employees
and enriches its shareholders without growing?
Because you can't amass capital.
Right?
And then that's capitalism.
You could provide lots of good lives
for everybody involved.
Absolutely. It's called steady state.
It's called there's lots of words
for a steady state economy,
steady state economy can take care of the whole world.
What it won't do,
is create multibillionaires.
It won't create people like, Elon Musk
must've got 6.7 billion in compensation.
That was his salary this year.
It just announced today.
I mean, just insane, insane amount of capital.
And what that capital is doing
is destroying the world for the rest of people
making, I mean, houses too expensive,
real estate too expensive.
I mean there's like the rich are pulling away
from the rest of the world,
Yeah, the wealth disparity gap
is just accelerating at an unseen obscene rate
and the pandemic just amplified it all.
Yeah it amplified it.
Yeah, and so I don't know
where that is going to hit the wall,
but it'll hit the wall again.
It can't happen.
It doesn't really pencil out.
I mean, only in, somebody's bankers wet dream.
So it doesn't need to pencil out ad infinitum.
It only needs to pencil out for my lifetime.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean, that's the mindset.
Or before I retire.
Yeah, right.
Take away my millions and...
Yeah, no appreciation for this idea
of indigeneity which is another subject in the book.
It is. Yeah.
But I do think the consumption thing
is something that really isn't being talked about.
You know, now there's so much openness
in terms of regenerative ag
and renewable energy and more and more,
people are forming around the idea that,
we have to really take care of nature,
which is kind of a funny revelation at this point,
but it's true.
But what they haven't done
is actually think about,
but how much are we using total?
Like individually in our cities
or our assumptions about what makes a good life
and all that sort of stuff.
I mean, virtually every one of my shirts
has a patch on the elbow.
I mean,
Paul, you martyr.
No, I think I'm proud of it.
I should've worn one today
so I gotta hold it up,
but I thought,
no, I'm going to be videoing with you too.
I got three shirts that don't have patches.
And, but the idea that it doesn't,
it's never made us happy more.
I mean, if you don't,
if you're poor yes.
More clothing, food, education, housing of course.
But once you reach a certain level...
It doesn't make you happy.
Excess accumulation that has no
relationship to happiness.
No, it doesn't.
And meanwhile, amidst that consumption,
there's a tremendous amount of waste, right?
We're wasting food,
We're disposing of our clothes.
Everything is disposable.
Yes. I mean,
clothing is considered to be 8%
of global emissions is due to the clothing industry.
Yeah. That's shocking.
It's the number two industry
in terms of waste and water number two.
I mean food.
The new report came out just last week,
that the number for food waste is 40%.
40% of our food is wasted.
That's wild.
It's crazy, and...
Where's the grave amount of that waste coming from?
The greatest proportion is the farm,
the second, but that depends on the continent.
Meaning they harvest
a portion of the harvest just gets tossed out
because it doesn't look nice.
And the grocery stores aren't going to buy it or whatever.
Ugly food, this, that all sorts of things.
But it depends, that's in Africa.
But if you go to north America
and the food is actually in the waste and supply chain
at the consumer level.
So it depends on which country,
I mean, that's an aggregate number,
but actually it's kind of deceptive
because it doesn't apply to Europe
the same way applies to Africa
where you don't have coal chains.
So, they don't have a coal chain
that makes it hard to preserve.
Sure, but in north America,
in the transport, in the chain,
from farm to grocery store,
or what have you, somewhere along the line,
stuff spoils
Oh yeah 25%
And then households throw away food
restaurants toss out food.
Yeah, they toss too much that they didn't cook.
And then if you don't have completed
finish your plate,
they have to throw it away.
Yeah, we did a podcast
with this chef Daniel Hume in New York,
and he's partnered with this organization called Rethink
are you familiar with what they're doing?
It's super interesting.
I mean, I think the most interesting part
of Rethink is the technological piece,
because so much of waste,
at least in the restaurant ecosystem
is a function of lack of kind of communication
and efficiencies that would allow,
that waste to go towards something good.
So if you can create like a network system
where and sort of efficiencies
for these restaurants to set aside
whatever food is getting wasted
so that it could be efficiently repurposed,
it's an easily solvable problem
with just a little bit of distribution effort involved.
It's the same thing.
It's reconnecting the broken strands.
Reconnect the system.
The way you heal a system
is to connect more of it to itself.
Whether it's your immune system, an ecosystem,
an economic system, a social system,
you connect more of it to itself
and we're radically disconnected.
And so when Daniel is doing there and Rethink is doing,
is saying, wait a minute, here's a source,
And here's the sync,
here's a need and here's a use.
Right.
And like, what if we do this?
What if we do this?
What are the logistics?
What's required?
How does the staff have to be trained ?
Once you make that shift,
It works automatically.
Right, you use like a human body analogy?
It would be repairing neurons
or basically stitching up arteries and veins.
So these things can flow.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, or unblocking them.
Right, yeah.
Well, in invasive surgery though.
You mentioned indigeneity
and indigeneity is actually
sort of the light motif of regeneration.
Actually, I mean, there's a piece on it,
but it actually it goes throughout.
And the reason is that
I'm white, I'm not indigenous,
but actually if I trace my ancestors all the way back...
You're indigenous to something.
Everyone is.
But not in my family's history or experience
nothing got passed down to me
about where I'm living and how to live there.
Right.
And the thing that we don't understand,
and I think we're starting to of course,
from the horrific way
that indigenous people have and are being treated
to this day,
is that they were amongst many things.
And I don't want to reduce it in any way,
but there's some of the best observational scientists
in the world.
And most of the science we rely upon today
is empirical science,
which is, it's not science, unless you can repeat it.
If not repeatable,
then it's just an observation.
It's just an happenstance.
It's just an...
and but the fact is in nature, nothing repeats,
and there is no lines and there's no circles.
And there's all the things that we rely upon,
but there's pattern
and there's pattern recognition.
And pattern recognition depends on time narrative stories,
oral traditions that pass on,
what is known language
in which the teaching of how to live in place
is embedded in the language
so that you have verbs that are essentially metaphors
for how to know where you are.
And it was Aristotle who said,
metaphor is genius.
And so when you start to look at
the 5,000 indigenous cultures on earth,
and you start to see
that they had extraordinarily knowledge
of the place that they lived.
How do we know that?
Because they'd been there
for 10, 12 thousand years or longer
in some cases and so forth
and through changes in weather
and all sorts of adaptation.
And so we have been the opposite.
We've actually, haven't lived in many places for very long.
But even if we have, sorry to interrupt,
like even if we had,
let's say, we've lived here for thousands of years.
We're not connected to the biosphere
in the manner in which those cultures were and are.
They had to be
'cause that's the only way they could survive.
Is to actually know where they were.
And so you see things like 3000 years ago
on the east coast and Lyla June who is on our board,
actually Denae and Cherokee activist, poet and scholar
wrote a piece called the forest is farm.
In what he talked about
was that if you do core samples in Tennessee
and around the east coast,
you find 3000 years ago,
a real shift in the pollen
and what was being grown in different trees
and different plants and animals
and food plants, and like what happened
and what happened is that native Americans,
in this case,
indigenous people transformed the forests into farms.
It was, that's where they got all the food
along with animals, all right.
And I was on a plane to Alaska
to give a talk at the university.
And I was sitting next to a woman
and we began to talk and she's Yupik.
And the Yupik people live on the Bering Strait
on both sides of Alaska and Russia.
And she was going out there
because her sister had died
and she became the elder.
And we started talking about it,
how it is to live on the Bering Strait, come on.
Right.
And she said that to live there,
they needed to be able to predict the weather
two years in advance.
What!
I was like, wait a minute.
I said, two years.
She said, oh yes, she's very humble, quiet woman.
And it wasn't, there was no bragging or pride,
nothing, nothing.
It was just matter of fact,
I said, well, how'd you do that?
And she started to name every single thing
that they saw over a course of a year observed.
And whether it was the color of the sea ice,
when it froze in the fall
and then melted in the spring,
the depth of it, the extent of it,
the type of velvet there was on the caribou,
the fish, they could tell from the fish,
how they had changed or subtle differences.
I mean, she just started naming the clouds.
They would look at the clouds.
They will look, she just named every single thing
in their environment.
And over obviously hundreds and thousands of years,
they began to say,
well, this, you put this and this,
when you've got those things,
that means that in or in the future,
or they had the memory of what happened two years ago.
So they had this type of weather,
they look back and say, yeah,
all I can remember in one of my....
And so these, and she said,
and they did it to survive.
Is that there was no,
and we can't predict it six weeks in advance here,
even two weeks in advance.
That's so wild
So it was amazing to know...
And so beautiful.
Yeah.
To be so intricately involved
and immersed in your environment
and to be so present and paying such close attention
to the smallest details
and to extract meaning out of that.
But they're just not just, they're just one culture.
Right, right.
It's true.
And to have Western culture be dismissive of that,
because it doesn't meet the criteria
of the quote unquote scientific method.
Right.
Exactly.
And now of course,
a lot of scientists are actually turning
to indigenous people,
but a lot of indigenous knowledge has been lost.
I mean, the elders died
and they were, you saw what happened in Canada,
I think it could happen here too.
Like their children were taken away,
they were murdered essentially in Catholic schools,
I mean, they were traumatized, they were belittled.
They were taken away from their native foods.
They were fed commodity foods full of sugar, fat and starch.
They got obese, they got type two diabetes,
they couldn't get jobs,
I mean all of what we did to them,
it wasn't them doing it to themselves.
And so, yet in some way, in most places,
they were able to maintain and keep this knowledge.
And these oral traditions passed on
generation for hundreds and hundreds of years,
from being harassed and hated by the colonists.
And so now I think we're realizing, gosh,
this is Alexandria library of knowledge.
that was right there all along,
except we didn't listen.
No, instead we dislocated them,
marginalized them, stole their land
and forced them into situations
where they have to open casinos.
Absolutely. Yeah.
And so, I mean, part of regeneration
people say, well, what does that have to do with climate
is absolutely to make amends
in whatever way we can today,
not just to indigenous people,
but actually, well, not to us,
I mean...
To the planet itself.
But African African-Americans
because they're indigenous people who were enslaved
and brought over.
There's 3000 different cultures in Africa.
And when we look at the roots
of regenerative agriculture in this country,
I mean the initial roots came from Africa
it didn't come from Asia.
They didn't come from any place else.
And can you imagine being a woman in Ghana
and for whatever reason
you've been kidnapped and then hurtled,
and then you're put on a boat
going to somewhere you don't know
that nobody can explain to you
that makes no sense at all.
And somehow these women braided rice
and seeds into their hair
and brought them to so-called new world.
and which is why the African-Americans
were the best rice farmers in all of Southeast America.
And when I started Erewhon
and started to grow organic rice
or get it grown actually for us,
I work with two black farmers in Arkansas
and their knowledge of rice was unbelievable.
And it went back for almost 400 years.
Wow!
And so...
That's a wild story.
I know we don't,
we have no idea where our food waste came from
or where the knowledge came from.
Of course, George Washington, Carver got that.
Right. I noticed him in the book too.
Like, talk about that a little bit.
Cause that's, I did not know about this either.
Well, I mean, he was the one who observed
that the difference between black farmers
and the results they were getting
and why farmers who were mostly cotton farmers,
cause it was the best cotton soil
where they were Alabama
and how they're they're playing out their farms
they were killing the soil, killing the farm.
And then on a nourishment level,
then of course, on the peanuts,
you're looking at groundnuts
as a source of both restoring soil,
but also restoring,
inexpensive way to provide a balanced nutrient
to people that they weren't getting at that time.
And, but it wasn't just him.
He had a whole bunch of other colleagues,
Tuskegee, they work together
and again, the roots of that,
and the benefit of that is,
throughout America to this day,
and we don't recognize.
Right.
I mean, when you,
I like not to keep bringing it back to this documentary,
but when you watch the biggest little farm
short of John and Molly finding some version of that,
like somebody who's steeped enough in soil ecology
to help guide them.
They would've never been able to make it work there.
And to think that there's this robust,
unbelievable cannon, a library of Alexandria
of this kind of wisdom and knowledge
based on millennia of observing nature,
that it's lost is crazy
because anybody who would carry that message
would be so valuable in so many ways
to anybody who's looking to tread a little bit more lightly
on the planet and to do things
in a regenerative symbiotic way.
And again, the other thing that we've lost,
maybe lost respect for is the language itself,
because there wasn't a written,
so it's not really an add-on or whatever.
And I remember being in Patagonia
and grinders museum and the Yamanote south Vietnam people,
depending on which name you use,
but, and there was like,
I don't know, maybe a few dozen left at that time.
I mean, there had been extirpated basically
by disease and by guns.
And Bruce Chatwin wrote a book in Patagonia
about the Yamen people and about their language.
And then I have a friend
who was, I grew up
at the university of California libraries,
where my father worked
in my family, marrying the librarian was hero.
She was really something.
And so I spent a lot of time at the library.
And so I understood from Bruce's book
that there was a dictionary
that there was a missionary who was down there
who had nothing to do.
And there was only a hundred or so Yamana people left
and he was a lexicographer.
So he made a dictionary
and worked with the tribal chief
but the tribal chief was really
that killed so many people.
He was like by default, but he wasn't.
And so for many years,
he made a dictionary of the Yamana language
into English Dictionary.
It was really amazing dictionary.
And they got to 30,000 words
and the missionary died.
And the Yamuna wouldn't talk to them about cosmology,
about women's issues and so forth.
They said, no, we don't trust you with this knowledge,
but they did talk about,
and if you read this dictionary,
it's like I said, it's a metaphor.
And like depression,
the word for depression
is a crab that's molting it's shell,
but it hasn't come off yet.
I mean, get out of here.
What!
I mean, it's such an exquisite language,
30,000 words.
And these are the people that Darwin called beasts
because when they came around, Tero De Fuego,
which it wasn't named then,
it was like they saw fire and smoke
and the foreign smoke was from the Yamana
who carried fire with them everywhere.
Cause it was cold,
but they were naked
because they put seal fat
all over the body to stay warm.
And they knew that clothing
would actually get wet and actually caused them to die.
So they were called beasts, right?
And they acted in strange ways and so forth.
Japanese has 40,000 words.
This dictionary had 30,000 words and is incomplete.
So...
It's wild.
So our understanding of indigeneity
of indigenous people is so broken.
And so...
Well it's metered in condescension, essentially.
They were not educated
in the manner in which we recognize,
so we're dismissive of them.
Yeah. We don't have the right lens to understand.
We don't have the right lens to see it,
understand it,
and frankly benefit from it.
And we were basically,
we saw them as beasts.
We use that word, not just Darwin
and as a subclass of species,
a subclass of human beings.
Well, yeah.
I mean, when you think of somebody like Paul Stamets,
who knows everything about mushrooms,
and now we're seeing this resurgence of enthusiasm
and interest in mycology
and what we can learn from the fungal universe,
creating foods from them
and just appreciating how much more complex
and amazing it is
than we ever imagined.
But in my mind,
he's in furtherance of that indigenous tradition
because he's so steeped in this one thing, right?
So imagine thousands of Paul Stamets,
who are experts in a wide variety
of different types of fields
that have to do with the cycles of the planet.
Yes.
And those people are coming
and there was,
there are respectful scientists now
and the Uswar and the Waorani and
they're in, in service,
in honor of their knowledge
and time then help also
to keep out, the miners,
the loggers, COVID as well
for that matter in the Amazon, in Peru, in Ecuador.
So there are some really wonderful things
going on now because of the respect
and understanding that was never there
or was hardly there and now is really growing.
And I think it also relates to a planet on fire.
And so who are you gonna turn to?
Obviously not Chevron, Exxon Odyssey,
not the Republican party,
and obviously not people who could care less
and these people who are so
I kind of, I don't want to be those people,
people who live in a place
and have cared for it so long,
have something to teach us.
About caring and about knowing,
and that we've lost or that we never had.
So in Paul Stamets, I mean,
when you think of his career and think of it,
I mean, he accidentally,
boiled up a whole bag full of psilocybin.
Somebody gave it to him,
he said just take a few,
he boiled the whole bag up and drank it
and then went up a tree,
he was, and then the thunderstorm came
and he was in that tree all night, long blowing around,
and it's for him to say,
but to me, I mean, Paul Stamets was born that night.
Right. He had a spiritual awakening.
He did, he absolutely did.
And his life path unfurled.
And he stuttered up until that moment.
And when he came down from the tree he did not,
he no longer stuttered.
Right.
And so that
he had in a very short night or maybe a long night,
but you have to be out there.
You have to be in nature.
You have to turn off everything that's on
and turn on everything that's off.
to you it's not off actually, and so forth.
And spend that time.
I spent three months once in silence
in the woods with nobody there.
You did?
Yeah, yeah.
When did you do that?
I did that about 14 years ago, 15 years ago,
So you had kind of a Walden pond experience.
I was just a caretaker at a refuge
that was in New Mexico
and it was during the winter
and early spring and nobody was there.
So I didn't speak to anyone.
Cause there was no one to speak to.
I mean, it was easy.
So you weren't setting out to have that experience.
It just was an occurrence by dent of...
well, what do you do everyday?
What do you do?
So what I did every day
was I would take off in a direction
and try to get lost.
I would just take off
and I never got lost except once.
That day I was like, ah,
I don't know where I am is so interesting.
Cause it's in this huge national forest,
and there's no roads, there's no houses,
there's no telephone poles.
There's no cell phone towers.
There's nothing to orient you.
And, but it gave me such a deep appreciation for the place.
And I remember once in the morning,
walking along the stream rivers
kind of right in between both
and literally a bear and I almost ran into each other
and the water was so loud.
It was in the early spring.
So it was rushing down through the snow
and I couldn't hear anything.
And I was looking one way,
it was looking the other way.
It was called cinnamon bear coat.
And it had, it must've been eating termites
from a dead log that had stuff all around whiskers
and we moved, we met each other and going,
oh shit.
I was like...
What do I do now?
Yeah, we looked at each other
And then we turned away.
Cause you know,
we both turned away
cause you're not supposed to make eye contact,
but you can see, you turn your head away,
but you can still see the presence of the other creature.
And it was so beautiful because it's a being,
it's not a bear.
I mean, it's a bear, but it's a being,
you're a being, there's two beings there.
And it's like, okay,
And we both kind of made a circle
around each other and kept going.
And so, and I remember nights
where I would just go out
and then just lean against the tree all night and sleep
or wake up and sleep all night just to...
and listen to the creatures and the birds
and in the morning at night,
and not so much present and night of course,
and I don't know what they were.
I mean there just sounds.
And those experiences are
Denali Paul's in the tree and not, and so Simon,
they're life changing.
They're life changing.
And when you hear terms like,
oh, we have to practice nature based solutions.
MBS is a called MBS is now by the client climatologist.
It's like, excuse me,
nature, nature, nature,
everything is nature and the idea that
there's nature based solutions
as if that was what nature was there for.
It's still that same colonial
way of looking at the world,
which others, the world that others nature,
it makes other nature seeing like other,
again, when I said about fixing it,
like well, what's the it climates it really.
Yeah. The idea
that we're gonna organize the world
in accordance to meet our needs.
Like, and yeah,
we'll make sure it's sustainable.
But the, the notion being that,
like we're even capable of that to begin with.
Yeah.
And the solutions exist for the benefit of us.
And we othered indigenous people
we othered them utterly.
We've othered everything.
Yeah. Everything I guess.
Yeah. In that sense.
And so that, this idea of regeneration,
the core of it
is to experience the inseparability
of everything and each other,
and to honor that and as I said,
the most important thing to do is to listen,
and nature as well and just the way we have led
and been taught to lead our lives,
has been so just fractured everything,
just shattered all the connections
that are actually intrinsically there.
And regeneration is that rediscovery.
And that's why I say, go, go to what is exciting to you?
That's the thing you're gonna do best.
And that's what's gonna turn other people on
and get them lit up and so forth.
And this idea and Andrew Huberman you...
Right, I love that he showed up in the book.
He sure did, he showed up because of...
I felt like you pulled that paragraph
right out of the podcast.
I did.
You're in this book,
you're in this book a lot more than you think you are.
Of course, I pulled that out
of the part, listening to you and Andrew
but the idea that beliefs change our actions,
if that was true,
we'd be in a very different situation today
with respect to climate
and the fact that it's actions that change beliefs.
And so people, the thing to do
is to do, go do, do whatever it is.
Just go do, start doing,
don't think about it.
And for God's sakes, don't worry about the numbers.
I mean, we have what I think now in the climate movement.
And I think drought on is partly responsible
is what I call climate voyeurism.
If we outnumber this, oh, it's 8% of emissions
is this or that is twice as that food is 34% of it.
But that's actually doing something calibrating.
Everything is actually solving the problem.
Yeah. Indexing exactly.
As like, well, I'm glad you know, it doesn't do anything.
And watching a documentary on Netflix
on climate doesn't do anything either.
It's like, we have to make sure
that we are actually doing something.
And with all due respect to my colleagues
and my friends and so forth,
and I can say this all day long,
they're still not doing anything.
They're not doing anything.
And that's why in the book,
we have punch lists
where we have a connection to the website,
which says, hey, make a punches.
Right. Yeah.
A big piece of this is,
we haven't even talked about it.
The nonprofit that is associated with the book,
regeneration.org,
where there's this tool kit
and all sorts of resources
to help people move in that Huberman way
from belief into the action
Absolutely. One of the things that I learned,
I did 128 speeches in 22 months for Drawdown.
You learn nothing when your mouth is open
and you learn a Q&A
because the Q's generally
are being asked for other people as well.
Maybe one person is brave enough to ask it,
but a lot of other people are going, hell yeah.
I wanna know too.
And so you learn from the questions,
and I can't
almost, without exception, somebody would say,
well, what should I do?
Or what should I do?
I don't know what to do.
It's interesting.
And there's a hundred solutions in Drawdown.
And they're asking that question
and Jasmine, my wife,
when I start regeneration said,
if you don't tell me what to do in this book,
I'm leaving you.
(both laughing)
I said, Got it.
So the book doesn't exactly do that by the way,
what it does is the last eight pages
is a wormhole to the website.
And there we have what to do.
You wanna know what to do?
It is the complete,
almost abbreviated manual
of what to do for challenges and solutions.
Challenge would be the boreal forest.
The biggest stock of carbon on earth
is being depleted with plush toilet paper,
open-pit mining, tar sands, et cetera.
Okay, that's a challenge,
that has to stop.
Okay, a solution is electrifying everything.
And that would mean putting in a heat pump in your house
to replace natural gas,
or it could be oil in the East coasts, whatever,
for heating, for water, can even be for cooking,
using an induction cooktop, that's a solution.
But what it does is like, okay,
this is what you can do as an individual. Okay?
This is all of the different levels of the agency.
This is what you can do as a neighborhood.
If there is something you can do,
this is what you can do as a school.
This is what you can do as a company
or ask companies to do as agents and so forth
and onwards, these are the influencers
who are causing problems.
Here's the email for the chairman of partner and gamble
who makes plush toilet paper.
You might want to write to him and say,
stop taking Virgin trees and making toilet paper out of it.
Bamboo works better anyway.
I learned that in the book.
Yeah, bamboo or recycled paper works a lot better
and cheaper.
And then here are the NGOs that are just kicking butt.
I mean, really are effective and influencing
and making a difference.
Here are the first nations
who are rising up speaking up,
talking about these are traditional tribal lands
that the first nations are dealing with in the boreal.
This they know the land better than anybody.
Here are videos, cool videos.
that'll teach you.
Here are books.
Here are the great books on the boil and so forth
here, et cetera.
So every solution and challenge
has whatever you wanna know,
or all your entry points.
We're not saying these are,
these are all the access to all the ways
you can actually be effective in this area.
That's what the book is sort of a neurotransmitter
to the website.
I mean, that's powerful.
The level of like practical advice
that you can give people
and they can plug in wherever they're enthusiastic.
Yeah, its my Huberman.
That's your action, mood follows action.
How's your mood.
Your mood is good, right?
Yeah.
What is the thing that you're most like,
I put that question to you, like,
what is the thing that you're most enthusiastic about?
I would say,
the thing that I'm most enthusiastic about
is the rate at which
people are rediscovering land
in all its myriad forms.
I shouldn't say,
I didn't know, but we researched it and found out
the terrestrial systems that is,
forests and grasslands and farmlands and coastlands
and mangroves and wetlands over
those hold 3,300 billion tons of C carbon, not CO2, C
the atmosphere holds one fourth of that.
It's four times as much carbon
that's in the atmosphere.
Okay. So there's two ways you can look at that.
Those systems are being degraded
and there was words we're
continuing to deforest.
We're continuing to use industrial ag.
We're continuing to overgraze.
We're continuing to dissertify the earth, et cetera,
to cover up our wetlands, et cetera.
So every time you do that,
then the life on the soil or in the soil,
perishes that's got C in it.
when C perishes, it combines with oxygen
produces carbon dioxide. Okay.
So in other words, it's emitting CO2, the greenhouse gas.
All right.
Okay so, if we keep doing this, right,
another 10% of loss
of our terrestrial systems that will increase PPM
from 419, what it is today,
418 to 519 like that It'll add a hundred PPM,
not reduce it.
Okay, now let's flip that.
Let's talk about a climate of optimism for a minute, okay,
Instead of pessimism.
So that means if we add 9% more C into all those systems,
9% is not a lot.
Then we sequester all the carbon we've admitted since 1800.
Wow!
And if we go to 14, 13, 40% depends.
We will also account for all the carbon
that is planned to be emitted by 2050.
So if you look at any place you live,
any place you love,
any place you've seen and say,
can we have a 10 to 12%, 14% improvement here?
Like more trees, more grasslands,
or can we change the grazing strategies and technologies?
Can we change the farming strategy?
Can we undesertify the two to 3 billion hectares of land
and so forth?
Heck yeah!
We can.
So that's just in protection.
That's not technology, that's not energy.
That's, there's many other things we can do
that are solutions that we've talked about.
It's just political on community well,
but if it's not asking a lot,
if every community could incrementally improve by 10%
through a variety of measures, it seems.
highly achievable.
Very achievable.
And so it's important that we have,
rather than the big pictures that came out today
from the IPCC about
whoa, it is here, it's irrevocable.
I mean, it's no question.
And you go, ah,
I mean, at the same time,
it's important that we have the opposite,
which is like, yeah.
And got it. Thank you for sharing.
Thanks for such fantastic science.
Let's go to work.
And this is the work
that can be done everywhere, by everyone.
And we can absolutely meet the challenge.
No question we need both.
And so it's not that the science,
or it's understandable
that the science has been couched and threat and fear
and all that sort of stuff.
I mean the scientists didn't know how to communicate
an activist took the science and used blame and shame
and finger pointing as a way
to thought they thought maybe that would make a difference.
I don't know, but both were right.
It's not that,
but they didn't conform to neuroscience.
Right, it's a natural,
psychological reaction to not being heard, right?
It's just frustration that builds into anger
and it's well-intentioned,
but it doesn't actually change minds or hearts.
No.
I think we're seeing that shift
across all forms of activism
because i mean you spoke about the gay rights movement.
I mean, you see that in the vegan movement,
like, all these sort of tried and true methods
that have been used for years
that just make people angry and divide people.
We're now realizing,
Hey, that's not such a good approach.
Exactly, in fact,
another figure ground shift from my point of view
was vegan the plant rich.
Vegan polarized, I mean, eat eggs.
I mean, but plant rich, like
I don't know if I coined it
or I know the first time I used it,
I hadn't seen it anywhere, but that was in Drawdown,
which is rich.
Like, first of all,
that's a great word and plants...
It's like gardening.
Plants is a great word. People love plants,
And so plant rich diet,
is like, so that's an invitation
come on in the water's fine.
Find your way into the world of plants.
You decide, you figure it out.
But again, it was like a figure ground shift
away from something that could cause people to resist
to something that was invitational.
And that's what regeneration is
an invitation to participate
is not, that's what it is come on in.
It really is fine. It works.
And why are you here
at this point, at this time,
given what we know,
what's your purpose?
What gives meaning to your life?
That's the question everybody's asked.
Yeah. we gotta end this in a couple of minutes,
but I can't let you go
without pulling on this last thread,
which is, and it's related to the psychology piece
that we were just discussing.
How do you,
let's say somebody is listening to this.
They're super enthusiastic.
They're good to go.
They wanna translate
that sort of emotionality into action.
Like we talked about,
but they're surrounded by a community of people
or family members or colleagues, et cetera,
that are unreceptive to this.
And they wanna be able to communicate effectively
their passion for this
to be a change agent for others.
So, given what we just talked about,
what are some strategies
for helping people communicate more effectively?
Don't use the word climate,
don't use the word global warming.
Those are macro issues and are conceptual.
And mean almost nothing to everybody really.
I mean, we use the term,
but they have no meaning.
And most of the jargon and acronyms around climate
have no meaning.
They're completely conceptual.
If you say somebody, 1 5C,
what does that mean to anybody?
Nothing.
I mean, somebody can understand it,
even do it to 2.7 F,
I'm making, figure it out
still means nothing.
And so to move completely away from climate speak,
because it's meaningless to most people
and to speak in ways that are meaningful
to the people who surround you.
And to the thing about carbon sequestration, for example
let's go back to soil, farming,
which is the purpose of regen Ag is not to sequester carbon.
That's an outcome.
It's really important to understand the difference.
The purpose of regen farm
farming for a farmer is to actually change their life,
to get out of debt,
to stop using poisons,
to poison their family or themselves, and so forth,
to increase their profitability,
to be proud of what they're doing
to absolutely become more resilient to drought
in too much water
so that the soil can be a reservoir instead of dirt.
I mean, you to create,
to increase the pollinators for your crops,
which are now dead and gone.
I mean, it goes on and on and on,
by the way, the outcome is more life in the soil
and that life is measured by C carbon, okay.
But that's an outcome, if somebody's paying for it.
Hallelujah. It's another crop you've got going for you,
but that is not the purpose.
And so the same thing with climate,
our purpose is to really take care of each other,
to improve the wellbeing of humanity on this planet
and all living creatures, all of life.
And we do that.
We reverse global warming,
but if you start with reversing global warming,
you've lost most people, right there.
Because you're putting the outcome
before the value.
The value, purpose.
But the thing that connects
that doesn't connect
I mean go to a party and somebody said,
oh, what do you do?
I'm a climate activist.
And they're going, oh, good.
Or just immediately.
Everybody has some association
with that negative or positive, right?
Baggage comes into play.
And everybody's made up their mind
how they feel about it
before the conversation even begins.
I mean, I like what you said earlier,
when you were talking about that town hall
and just having people raise their hands
and identify what their values are.
Absolutely.
Through that you discover this commonality,
this like, shared sensibility that we can unite over.
If you're sitting next to somebody
and you say I'm a climate activist,
I'm trying to save, the rainforests
they are going, oh, cool.
If you say like,
oh, I'm trying to save the world
which even more ineffective.
But if you say...
you sound like an asshole.
Like( chuckles)
Well, there's so much hubris in that.
What are you doing?
I'm saving the world.
That's all for us,
but you can't do anyway.
But if you say
I discovered this way,
if smartphones are being thrown away.
And what I started to do in this place in Peru,
I started to nail them up to trees
and connect them together
with little tiny solar cells kept them charged.
And that way the indigenous people there
could hear every time a chainsaw started up
and go with and find exactly where it was and stop it.
Right.
Then you're like, tell me more.
What is that forest?
And how'd you figure that out.
And I mean, it opens up the conversation,
but you're doing something
and there's specifics to it.
And that's what somebody is doing by the way.
I'm not saying that.
And so it again,
it's really about reconnecting,
and you can't connect
by thinking that somebody should connect
to the place where your head is.
We have to connect where our values are common.
No, you're a beautiful man Paul Hawken.
I love being with you.
Thank you so much.
You are a gift to humanity and the planet.
I could talk to you for hours and hours and hours.
And I really appreciate you coming here today
and sharing your wisdom and experience.
Thank you and I have to say again,
your wisdom and your drawing out of wisdom
is in the book.
I appreciate that.
I really I'm humbled by that statement.
No, it really is.
I listen, I mean,
and it's made a really big difference.
I'm glad to hear it.
Yeah.
And I'm excited for people to check it out
regeneration Ending the climate crisis in one generation
comes out September 16th
14th,
14th
whatever.
You can get it now though.
Yeah you can pre-order it now
it's a beautiful book.
And I think it's gonna really inspire a lot of people
into the action piece, right?
Right.
Cool.
Well come back and talk to me again sometime.
All right.
All right
Peace plants.
(electric guitar playing)